so that's the that's my rib concern is
that we may see transportation policy
get totally warped by climate change
politics if we don't really invest in
the right places in the right way with
these congestion relief projects in our
urban areas and with the goods movement
projects on the long-distance
interstates we get poorer as a country
than we otherwise would be I mean
transportation really is the lifeblood
of the economy eighty to eighty-five
percent of all the goods that we use in
this country by value transfer go most
of their way by truck
number one problem is urban traffic
congestion I mean the city's every
single year our major ten or twenty top
urban areas get more and more congested
and we spend more and more every year
but we're spending it on the wrong
things and in the wrong places so that's
no problem
one is massive traffic congestion costs
indirect cost alone in terms of wasted
time and fuel about sixty five billion
dollars a year and the real total cost
is probably about double that when you
look at the how it dampens the
productivity of the economy but making
it hard for both people to get to jobs
and for goods to get efficiently and on
time to just-in-time delivery system
stuff like that the other is that the
interstate highway system which was a
huge productivity gain for the economy
when it was built in the starting in the
50s and on through the 60s and 70s is
starting to wear out
I mean concrete pavement life is you
know only typically 30 or 40 years
before it needs complete rebuilding and
also a lot of it doesn't have enough
lanes it's now much more costly to
rebuild it in today's dollars than it
was to build it originally and the gas
tax has simply hasn't kept pace gas tax
is a tax on the number of gallons
consumed and so as we've doubled fuel
economy over the last 25 years we go a
lot further on a gallon of gas and this
is gonna get much worse in the future as
we start having more hybrids and
electric cars and those kind of stuff so
we have you know the the funding the
revenue in real terms is going down
while the need for rebuilding and
modernizing pre structure is going up so
the system is just out of whack
the private sectors role I think is
really crucial because in contrast to
the political process that decides where
to spend money based on all kinds of
political horse trading and making sure
that every member of Congress gets to
announce projects and cut ribbons the
private sector looks at these says and
says where do we get a return on
investment so it's a totally different
mindset and a totally different
evaluation process the private sector
looks at where are the critical needs
that that people would pay to get better
mobility and urban traffic congestion is
job number one on that to score I mean
if you if people are wasting directly
sixty five billion dollars a year that
suggests some willingness to pay some
portion of those people would be willing
to pay to get relief to have congestion
free lanes that would charge a price a
variable price to keep them free-flowing
it's very very well-known that most
people will only commute a certain
number of minutes each way per day they
you know you always have a distribution
you have outliers who are willing to
commute an hour or an hour and a half
that's that's the long tail of the
distribution the vast majority of people
it tends to be between twenty and thirty
minutes each way so okay you think you
you locate a house your residence into a
place how far can you go a radius of
thirty minutes around that location is
where you're willing to accept a job
well the reason we have urban areas is
cause something called agglomeration
ikan all economies that you have a lot
of people in close proximity you can
make better deals value-adding deals so
if a company can recruit it wants to be
in an urban area cuz it has a bigger
base to recruit from but the circle the
radius around each company from which it
can recruit shrinks over time the worst
congestion gets the shorter the distance
that people can go
Obama is has a lot of people around him
who were very concerned about global
warming and greenhouse gases and there's
a real danger that transportation policy
is gonna get significantly warped by an
overriding focus on whatever we do it
has to be stuff that dramatically
reduces greenhouse gases whether it
makes good sense or not whether the cost
per ton of co2 reduced gets to
astronomical levels it looks good it
feels good like trying to massively
shift people from driving to riding
light rail in places where it just
doesn't make any sense but you could
spend a fortune on doing those things
and have hardly any improvement either
in greenhouse gases or in reduced
congestion but you can you know you
could fritter away hundreds of billions
of dollars on projects like that that
just don't make sense and leave go the
critical needs to invest in the in the
enhancements to the highway system that
would serve the vast majority of people
in in almost all of our metro areas that
are now driving and will continue to
drive because even with the congestion
it's still the most flexible thing for
the kind of trips that they actually
have to make in the life as we really
live it so that's the that's my real
concern